thinking of being a protector if women  expect men to pay for sex why don't men  expect women to pay for bodyguards uh  because they're stupid why do women  often describe men as stupid but then  expect love from them in return  um why do we describing that stupid  because we've been through a lot of  stuff so because but isn't it fair to  say a lot of men have been through a lot  of stuff as well they have but I feel  like you know sometimes you get a good  woman and you treat her like [ __ ] and  then you expect us to not call you  stupid when you do us dirty and then  we're standing there looking stupid but  yet you are the stupid ones because  guess what they always come back